no 1 en mi temps direct avec nous loïc
pen médecin à l'hôpital de creil et
membre du collectif des médecins cgt et
francis palombes et si le président de
la confédération des commerçants de
france
messieurs bonjour merci d'être avec nous
sur rt france and open vous êtes médecin
le pass and i ter à quel point est il
indispensable selon vous dans la gestion
de la pandémie
non le débat sur le passé ni terreau est
il est biaisé
ce qui est indispensable c'est d'obtenir
une vaccination la plus complète
possible d'avoir des gens vaccinés
partout en france après le passage hiver
on les fait cette décision
vise à donner des sueurs d'emmanuel
mâcon puisqu'il ne n'avais pas les
moyens politiques par manque de
confiance qu'elle a à b et d une des
personnalités reculé sur sur votre
chaîne de la viande le dis il ya une
scène est question de confiance dont ils
n'avaient pas les moyens de rendre une
vaccination obligatoire parce qu'en
effet cette crise a été extrêmement mal
géré c'est elle et elle masque les doses
il ya eu des mensonges permanents et
donc aujourd'hui pour rendre ce qui est
utile une batterie nation la plus large
possible il a recours à un pas de
sanitaires il va falloir qu'on règle ce
problème rapidement c'est-à-dire en
aboutissant à ce que la vaccination soit
la plus large possible c'est ça qui l'a
fait retomber pas salutaire et pour cela
et bien il va falloir continuer la
campagne de vaccination et aller vers
les gens qui aujourd'hui ont des
interrogations légitimes quand on leur a
menti ce temps durant toute une période
de gestion de crise il se pose
naturellement des questions là les 3000
soignants qui sont suspendus c'est cette
situation extrêmement difficile puisque
nous avons besoin de se soigner dans les
hôpitaux nous sommes déjà dans des zones
où manquent de personnel et pour les
convaincre et bien il va falloir aller
rediscuter parce que dans la plupart des
cas certains hôpitaux ont fait le squad
allait discuter avec leurs personnels
d'autres donc juste appliquer la loi or
après tout ce qu'on nous a raconté
thomas carabistouille il ya besoin
vraiment d'aller discuter que les
médecins allaient disputer avec les
personnels qui sont réticents pour
expliquer l'enjeu de cette vaccination
france et sa palombière vous êtes
bonjour vous êtes d'accord avec monsieur
peine est ce que vous estimez moi aussi
qu'il a eu un problème au niveau de la
communication du gouvernement et la
façon finalement dons qu'ils ont parlé
aux français
oui il ya il ya eu il ya un corps mais
peut-être un peu moins que cela était le
cas il y a des une communication qui n'a
pas toujours été vraiment préciser
suffisamment clair moi bien sûr je ne
suis pas dans la catégorie des soignants
dans la situation de mon collègue qui
est à l'antenne mais je suis le
président de la confédération des
commerçants de france donc je porte des
acteurs du commerce c'est évident que
les manifestations s'ils se sont
déclenchées à la suite de ce pas
salutaire
obligatoirement intact le commerce ça
crée une ambiance dans certains endroits
à paris et en province des crispations
les commerces ne peuvent pas s'exprimer
et vendre normalement alors qu'ils ont
été fermés pendant longtemps bon état
sanitaire comme l'a dit mon collègue
la vaccination c'est une fin en soi mais
il faut surtout pas je pense dans un
pays démocratique comme la france en
arriver à comme certains partis
politiques bon signifier l'obligation de
se vacciner pour le moment il dit à la
possibilité de se tester bon c'est bart
c'est pas quelque chose de réjouissant
mais pour autant ça prend quelques
instants et on peut attester koné
négatif si on est négatif on est même
moins contagieux ou moins impactant que
si on est vacciné puisqu'avec le vaccin
il ya quand même idée il ya quand même
des différences qui s'applique donc
je pense qu'il faut que en aille vers
une destination encore accentuée pour en
finir avec l'état sanitaire on a entendu
de la part du président de la république
ces dernières semaines ces derniers
jours des lueurs d'espoir quand même
nouveau président a dit si dans
certaines régions dans certains lieux il
n'y a pas
matière à danser sur le plan de la
circulation du virus on lèvera les
mesures du passage du ter petit à petit
donc il ya quand même le bout du tunnel
que l'on commence à entrevoir et ça
c'est très important
voilà ce que je pourrais dire par
rapport aux commerçants et puis il y à
une catégorie socioprofessionnelle du
commerce et les centres commerciaux qui
dans certains cas
ils ont échappé dans beaucoup d'autres
cas parce que les tribunaux leur ont
donné raison et les préfectures mais
pour autant
l'obligation de la vaccination pour le
personnel des magasins
le pass annie terre à l'entrée du centre
commercial vous doutez bien que c'est un
gros impact négatif sur l'expression du
commerce donc il faut en sortir et pour
en sortir il faut la vaccination en
parallèle monsieur permis justement il
devenu une machine arrière concernant le
pass annie terre dans les centres
commerciaux ce nouveau qu'est ce qui a
permis à finalement ce changement de ton
ce changement de ton a été à la suite
s'est révélé à la suite de négociations
très fortes qui ont engagé la fédération
des centres commerciaux qui est très
très active très dynamique et les
préfectures ont quand même constater que
la part du danger n'était pas à la
hauteur
de la nécessité de se passer ni terre
donc il y à il ya bien parce que on a
fait le parallèle
quand on rentre dans une grande surface
commerciale dans un grand hypermarché
il n'y a pas il n'y a pas les mêmes
règles que pour le centre commercial et
ce n'est pas logique rien y'a quand même
des trous dans la raquette dans
l'application et dans la communication
ce qui a amené les préfectures dans
certains cas mais il trouve à l'appui
avec des statistiques sanitaires précise
a retiré cette obligation dupas
sanitaires et je m'en félicite pour mes
collègues des chambres commerciaux dr
peine on a entendu à tout à l'heure
monsieur bah non vie inquiéter optimiste
sur la suite à ce que vous partagez
justement cet optimiste qu'on a vu que
les 50 millions de primo vacciner hier
c'était un seuil qui avait été franchie
hier on a des indicateurs et épidémies
qui ne sont pas si mauvais on a une
manuelle macron qui laisse entrevoir que
peut-être il y aura en tout cas un
assouplissement niveau du pass and i ter
est ce qu'on peut espérer le meilleur
pour la meilleure je pense que on a
critiqué parfois on critique quand il
faut critiquer d'une somme de 5,8 à
merville voilà nous sommes des syndicats
nous aussi et nous sommes des syndicats
professionnels mais quand le président
de la république manifeste des propos
qui vont dans le sens de la sortie de la
suppression du pass petit à petit moi je
dis que le discours positif sur le plan
sanitaire c'est nécessaire sur le plan
économique avec la relance et on se rend
compte quand même que l'état est
heureusement va continuer au cas par cas
d'une manière ciblée à entre à londres à
soutenir les entreprises comme ça a été
le cas depuis le début de ce que 8,19
mais justement si on a sauvé beaucoup
d'entreprises s'il y a un minimum de
faillite eh bien il faut que l'état
continue et en tant que syndicat du
commerce je le demande au gouvernement
nous avons des rencontres permanentes
avec alain griset notre ministre et
bruno le maire donc il faut sortir de
cette impasse il faut commencer à
entrevoir la sortie de cette crise
terrifiante terrible qui a sévi sur
notre pays docteur peine est-ce que vous
aussi vous pensez qu'on a raison d'être
optimiste pour la suite
non la vaccination
progresse nous avons loin
d'hospitalisation nous avons raison
d'être optimiste on est sur une pente
positive en effet permis aux penguins
n'attend rien des manuels macro lui qui
était la vaccination sont les français
matinée et qui occupait cette démarche
et voilà une bonne démarche
après nous n'avons pas risqué quand même
c'est l'apparition de nouveaux variants
parce que n'oublions pas que or en
france on a un peu quand même des
preuves de riches on est sur la
discussion sur la vaccination la plupart
des pays aujourd'hui en voie de
développement n'ont pas de vaccin et en
réclament
parfois ce qui se passe ici qu
et c'est une pandémie nous avons un
problème qui les parents c'est qui est
mondial tant que nous ne vaccinerons pas
plus largement la population mondiale
nous risquons l'apparition de nouveaux
bars et nous n'avons pour l'instant pas
d'autres aux arbres que ces vaccins qui
permettent d'arrêter à cette pandémie
l'instant il ya pas traitement on a lu
les chèques la chloroquine l'échec de
l'échec de l'ivermectine canarde la
difficulté de maîtriser cette pandémie
quand la vaccination n'est pas
suffisante il n'est pas la seule
explication dans les dom tom la
situation catastrophique de leur
possible maintenant la bande au démon
équipant les années est aussi une
explication n'est là on voit bien qu'il
ya nécessité banksy chi l'ha qu'en bas
de la nation mais pour l'instant nous
n'avons toujours pas autorisé la levée
des brevets sur les 24 pour une affaire
de gros sous et ne l'avons pas une
amende du coup permet le transfert
technologique permettrait de fabriquer
largement ce vaccin rro oui je suis
positif mais avec une inquiétude c'est
le retour d'un variant des pays non
vaccinés qui pourrait nous replonger
dans des difficultés une nouvelle donc
besoins non pour les vaccinations se
fera naturellement tomber les histoires
de passe à lithaire peut
infiniment gestion de la crise sanitaire
par ce gouvernement et nous avons besoin
de nous battre pour obtenir la levée des
bretelles d'accès et leur diffusion par
dans le monde parce que nous sommes sur
une seule planète ont pas assez
conscience si les populations de tous
deux duos entier ne sont pas vaccinés
nous reverrons naturellement moins
d'épargnants de ce virus avec tous les
banquiers nous ont été atteints ou
liberty à lille
elles peuvent opter par mais j'ai pas vu
le week-end merci d'avoir répondu à ma
question je rappelle que vous êtes
médecin à l'hôpital de creil et membre
du collectif des médecins cgt merci à
vous également francis rapp à l'envi
êtes président de la confédération des
commerçants de france par tiago de
messieurs